as you cool this material when I say  cold I don't mean put it down in the  freezer I'm talking on a Kelvin absolute  temperature scale you just keep getting  this colder and colder and colder and  the wavelengths of each of these  particles gets longer and longer right  and you reach a point  where all the wavelengths  overlap each other for every single  particle  and they become one  they've condensed they they've condensed  and become one functioning particle oh  okay they didn't just condense and  become a solid thing no all their waves  which used to be separate and distinct  are now overlapping and resonating with  each other they're the Voltron of  particles yes there it is